and then they go to school and they get
groomed again by the maoist freaking
education program
the social emotional learning and the
queer theory and the gender theory and
the the critical race theory that
they're using exactly not to derail our
conversation but i'm so pissed off that
they literally recreated maoism in our
schools literally but and
totally tricked everybody what bothers
me the most is when we we have guests
who come in here who are like moderate
or conservative or you know understand
what's going on and they just like
will block like very like nonchalantly
be like yeah you know my kids going to
college and so they're we're trying to
figure out where to send them to and i'm
like why why do orange aren't you like
savvy to what's going on politically
you know i saw this story on reddit
where a guy was like i sent my daughter
off to college and she came back and now
she hates me i don't understand what
happened and i'm like maybe you should
pay attention to your children and their
lives
you know so you think you can send your
kid to an institutionalized learning
facility and they won't be indoctrinated
i'm sorry you know you need to you need
to wake up and make sure you're paying
attention to what your kids are doing i
mean that's even a problem when you
don't have a maoist structure right and
like i don't know
if you guys i don't know if anybody
knows no american knows how freaking
maoism worked is actually very simple
mao created a list of bad identities
right that's it they called them black
identities we'll get the critical race
theorists to work on that later they'll
call them white identity but it was yeah
well it was yeah exactly so but it was
it was for fascism and so these were
people that were like wealthy land
owners you know landlords um you know
wealthy farmers stuff like that uh bad
influence was one of them and then he
created these other identities read for
communism that were good identities and
they were things like peasant and
laborer but then also revolutionary
activist things like that and so what
you would do is you take kids in the
school and be like oh your dad's a
wealthy farmer black identity you're the
biggest problem in the world you're
connected to the biggest problem of the
world guess what join our movement
though and you can have a red identity
like all the other cool kids and you get
to wear a red hat or whatever the little
prize is for the kids that are the good
guys what are you doing now well you're
white so you're complicit in racism you
are a racist but you can be an ally
you're black you don't even know how the
system works so you're complicit in
racism but you can become politically
black you can become a black voice
you're a
12 year old girl you're confused you
have white skin you're the worst kind of
person but did you know that if you
transition and become a queer activist
you have a positive social identity now
someone that's exactly how mao did it
that's exactly what they're doing in
school
we had a good super chat from someone
they said i like how only white people
can be racist and black people can't be
racist but candace owens is a white
supremacist yeah well i want to ask real
quick have you spoken to lily tang
williams yeah i met her okay okay great
i was gonna say i think you two would
have a great comment oh yeah she's
awesome
one of the things that terrifies me
about this being like maoism back is one
of the things mao did was talked about
rightists he was all the righteous all
right so when i hear the language of
whenever even us our my friends and
we're talking when someone's like those
on the left i feel like mal has already
indoctrinated you sir if you're if
you're thinking in terms of left and
right mao has indoctrinated you i don't
think so the terms left and right go
back to the french revolution and even
that was like just a couple of the the
side of the aisle they sat on it wasn't
a political ideology but it was i mean
we named the political ideologies after
this after the side of the aisle sitting
on but the ideologies were completely
irrelevant to the side of the aisles
they sat on at the time and it's a
mistake to split people in half like
this right now the revolutionary stuff
did it you did it on purpose yeah there
there there are two parent factions and
we could call now once we think
are there two parent factions in the
culture war yeah there are there
we could call them right and left but
they're the we
call it one and two we call it a and b
what about what we call it can we call
them and then the others i mean how bad
do you want to divide these people right
now it's not about wanting to do
anything
unity cannot come at the expense of
truth these people are saying things and
doing things that are horrific and we
need to speak out against that and
acknowledge that their goals are
separate from ours the truth is also is
through the vessel it's spoken your
perspective on truth is different from
so no no we talked about the jon stewart
thing earlier and i said i didn't know
if i should name it that but that's
exactly actually what mao was doing they
had labeled rightists as people who were
against the glorious revolution so
anybody who was against the glorious
revolution was in this black category
and was a rightist and so the goal was
to stain anybody who wanted to keep the
existing society
largely intact in its structure as
somehow
morally polluted well morally polluted
stupid too stupid to understand the need
for the glorious revolution or crazy and
then the goal was to turn the people
into thinking that everybody who liked
the existing society
may be thinking it's imperfect but that
the general structure is pretty good and
we should try to reform within it rather
than have a revolution that gave mao all
the power those people
are the problem and everybody who wants
to be on the right side of history which
is a hegelian marxian idea
everybody wants to be on the right side
of history now has to be
against those people so the divide and
conquer the splitting um
what what you're saying is you know mao
wanted to split people yes for his own
power and what tim is saying is
uh it's just subjective reality that
somebody's splitting us into two
different factions that have but there's
there are two parent factions also
because there are two very different
structures for how society is to be
organized that literally comes all the
way back down to subject versus object
do you think in terms of the subject do
you think in terms of the objective
world outside
there's a bunch of ways it's been
described authoritarian versus
libertarian sure there's uh a great way
that was described to me by uh stephen
marsh which is a multicultural democracy
and a constitutional republic both
existing within the same borders which i
find really interesting as well i don't
think necessarily anyone kind of gets it
my view of it is actually
judeo-christian moral framework versus
marxist lack of moral framework a moral
framework lack thereof so
the way i see it is when you look at the
constitution you look at the ideas of
liberalism or liberty classical
liberalism et cetera a lot of it is
rooted in
a a
rel i just christian moral framework i'm
gonna start calling abraham
a lot of what marxism has done is just
bastardized christian principles so i
think it's interesting that you pointed
out this idea of the the hegelian notion
of being on the right side of history
that history has an end i mean when you
consider it that is a christian idea in
some sense that's been twisted into
something else called the ideas yeah
yeah their eschaton is our political
order prevails i'll put it this way
that's right so uh whether whether
people in this country realize it or not
if even the atheists their moral
framework is rooted in christianity yeah
not not 100 percent it's not like they
follow the bible it's just that a lot of
the ideas they hold true to themselves
they don't realize what the root of that
is so there is a traditional view in
terms of what is right and what is wrong
which comes from christianity
for the the the you know race marxists
for the woke for whatever this other
group is they don't have those moral
frameworks they have an inverted one
yeah in fact it's one bird actually i
think it's lack thereof it's whatever
suits their power well that's
yes
they do have a vision though which is
that that everything comes from when
when they achieve their utopia and so
the whole thing is actually a pretty
vastly religious structure and the
reason is because
kind of tracking back to you know say
the 19th century you have basically god
versus society is kind of the two
explanations of what's going on or god
versus self and
you know god has ordained this moral
order this is the judeo-christian order
that you're looking at what marx
actually said is no we're gonna this is
his 1844 you know so-called paris
manuscript or his epistle what is it um
economic and philosophical manuscripts
1844 from paris and he says no what
we're going to do
is we're going to abandon that we're
going to make man in himself independent
of everything man is going to become
the deity but not any man only awakened
man a gnostically awakened man if we
want to get really technical only awaken
man who has a correct consciousness and
that consciousness is a social
consciousness or in other words a
socialist consciousness and so when man
and society become co-continuous so that
man is for society and society is making
man
so that they're the same as total
socialism then you have actual eye this
is the hegelian part you have actualized
the deity the deity comes in in the form
of society as man as society which is
totally hard to get your head around
because it's this dialectical [ __ ]
but what that stands to do is replace
god and so what that in and it's their
moral framework
anything that brings that into existence
is good anything that resists that is
bad so anything that gives them power is
good and as a matter of fact just to i
know you're i don't want to keep going
but if you go to marxist.org and you
look up they have an encyclopedia it's
awesome i love it i read it a lot they
tell you exactly what the hell they mean
by all these crazy words they use um you
look up the word for truth and they
straight up tell you a lot of people
think that truth means correspondence to
what's actually happening in the
objective world but for marxist it's a
social formation and then they go on and
say well the rationalists think that
truth is in reason and the empiricists
think that it's an evidence and the
pragmatists think that it's in what
works but for marxists it's closest to
the pragmatists but it must wed theory
and practice so it is what brings
marxism into the world is true i i think
a big component of the culture war may
be do you believe in a greater power
than yourself that doesn't mean god
doesn't mean you're religious
when i think about inalienable rights
why i believe in freedom it's because i
feel that i am uh
i am i am a a tiny insignificant
fragment of the universe relative to the
greatness and vastness of the universe
personally i do believe in god yeah um
not i'm not i'm not theistic like any
particular religion but so when i think
about other people's lives and their
rights and and what they're entitled to
i think there's something beyond me and
you know i respect other people's
existence yeah
but for the woke their view is there is
nothing the power is them if they're if
they're to take it they can be gods so
you think about that's right you think
about the world economic forum you think
about transhumanists you think about the
people who are like can we transcend and
i recommend um i recently just played
the video game for uh horizon forbidden
west
zero dawn was awesome that came out a
while ago forbidden west is the new game
that just came out i'm not going to
spoil it because it's really new but if
you like these conversations play that
game i'm a little underwhelmed by the
writing but it plays in a bit to this
and it's it's really fascinating
concepts outside of the kind of weak
story they made but concepts about
transhumanism and things like this are
really really fascinating because these
people think they're gods well that's
right because marx
marx actually the the belief is that the
subject and the object and this is why
it does dichotomize it's people that
center the subject versus people that
center the object
marx believe that these two are in
dialectical relationship he also took
this from hegel who believed that the
the the deity will actualize when the
subject and object are synthesized this
was the hegelian systemic systematic
philosophy so marx took it from there
and he actually the goal for marxist is
that you are a subject you can envision
i want to create the blade i see the
blade in my mind i know what maul sword
should look like and then i go get a
piece of apparently brass and bang on it
with a hammer and hopefully don't give
myself zinc poisoning when i put it in
the uh catch fire don't rag on my my
anime i'm just saying
he's a blacksmith i'm just saying don't
put brass in a forge without proper
ventilation just don't do it so then you
bang you create the thing with your
hammer right your sickle is for when
you're hungry and you create the thing
and so in the object you see
that you created that which was in your
subjective vision and so you recognize
yourself as
creator
you recognize yourself as somebody who
has the capacity to shape the world and
then when you see this not only can you
shape mall sword not only can you shape
wakasashi not only can you shape zelda
sword or whiskey g or whatever it
happens to be whiskey as the chinese for
whiskey by the way uh
i know all the people are gonna be like
it's bojo no whiskey g is a thing they
actually say when they talk about like
american whiskey um i know that because
my chinese person every time my friend
every time i drink he doesn't speak
english and every time i drink whiskey
he's like whiskey
you know he gets really excited and so
anyway um
the goal is that you also have to shape
man and society as your objects so you
have to create
socialist consciousness in man including
yourself but everybody else as well and
then you also have to shape society to
become a socialist society so that when
those two fuse you now have the
perfected society this is literally the
religion and i mean religion it is
fundamental correct term of marxism
and this is the operating system behind
the entire thing and race marxism or
critical race theory is the same thing
you're just doing it now in the racial
justice council all three of us have our
hands up yeah i just want to say real
quick
talking about the mall sword
that mall sword he has to defend it
there was there was a point in time
where that would have been the pinnacle
of weapons technology
and it's like it cost like fifteen
dollars but the brass is fake
i don't i think that's probably just
like aluminum garbage or something but
but the point is the way it's shaped and
like it's easy for us to make something
like that
some you know ancient tribe would have
been like wow yeah is that like to bind
the blade that little hook that little
at the bottom there if it catches the
blade to bind it i mean i guess probably
it's in it's like it's a mall sword it's
a monster it's there to look at a piece
of metal that's like you know a toy
i i love that you reference the fact
that this is very clearly a religion and
one of the uh christian principles that
heroes have sort of been bastardized
here is this idea of like cooperating
with god in creation but where the huge
distinction here is is marxists see
human beings as objects as you described
which can be reformed in their own image
so in that way they really start to play
god i think right that's exactly right
yeah and
it's interesting too because tim sort of
mentioned that we have this christian
framework that a lot of people don't
realize they're following and i would
also argue our culture has a marxist
framework and
on top of that you mentioned the marxist
framework but i think there are a lot of
people including in the conservative
movement who don't realize they're
following the marxist framework as well
and in many cases even more closely than
they are the christian framework so
there are a lot of marxist assumptions
that our culture currently takes for
granted one example would be that
without any qualification equality is
always an inherent good but of course
that's ridiculous right we should not
treat a pedophile the way would we would
treat a law-abiding citizen in some
instances you need inequality and
justice is more important we shouldn't
treat the guy who runs way faster than
the other guy equally when it comes to
handing out medals either exactly
exactly there is a necessity for people
to be treated unequally in certain
circumstances i would argue another way
in which we've assumed marxist thinking
or taking it for granted is that we can
solve problems including moral problems
with a more equitable distribution of
resources so what the marxist said for
so long was that if we just more
equitably distribute resources and
workers own the means of production all
of these social ills will fall away and
then instead of saying that's absolutely
nonsense because there's more to human
beings than the materials they're made
of and they need something deeper the
conservative movement today responds by
saying no no no yes of course recess
resource distribution is the most
important thing but those resources are
distributed better by capitalism as
opposed to marxism thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you